[Music]
if the epicenter of the corona virus
outbreak in Europe is in Lombardy
province in northern Italy then the
absolute center of this epidemic is here
in the town of Bergamo more people have
died here than anywhere else and they
still are everyday the virus storm swept
through these beautiful ancient streets
this medieval town and it's modern city
is utterly locked down only a few
venture out everyone knows someone who
has died or is ill and everyone is
scared prophecy Dolorosa non-potable
saluted Oloroso lishala solely the
christeta multi three states
seen on a rapport a very appropriate a
proper n take a Cinnabon o piano piano
propio cozy vida de la gente que su
prodigal moon way chair querida salvar
into t ma d epidemic 0.92 possibility'
opera prank funny family family here
they believe the only way to stop the
spread of the virus is to shut
everything only essential shops are open
it is hard but it is according to the
experts the only solution the man tasked
with dealing with this crisis while
protecting his family and leading his
community is the mayor Giorgio Gauri he
imposed the lockdown is your message to
the outside world if you like that you
have to love passionately yes absolutely
yes I I have two daughters they are
studying in England one in Taunton in
college and the other and the other in
Canterbury she's doing a master and when
I so what did the English government was
thinking about this and this problem I
decided to bring them back because I
think that even if we are at the center
of the message academia
yep the epidemic probably there are
probably more secure sure here than done
in England because I don't understand
why the government didn't decide for
time in time to protect the citizens in
Bergama the only people allowed to
gather always keeping apart are coming
to the town hall to register the deaths
of family members this is the old wall
city in the city of Bergamo this was the
hardest hit when the virus first came
it's the most hit city in the most hit
province in the most
hit country Italy in Europe and widely
regarded as one of the most dangerous
places in the world at the moment
because the virus is so variant here it
is an empty it looks it but it isn't
it's full of people but they are all
self isolating they're all following the
rules very few people come out onto the
streets and everyone we've spoken to
have said that this is what the UK
should look like already the vast
majority of those dying here are in the
high-risk elderly group Serena and
mikela are both 73 they came out to get
some Sun for the first time in days they
never leave each other and they meet no
one they're still scared
super gamma sempron an Akuma created a
queen named their aura so no continuity
now mainly Cassady the number of dead
here continues to rise they don't
believe they've reached the peak yet
times are strictly allotted for the
funerals of loved ones to take place and
there's a huge backlog they break the
curfew to pay their last respects at the
town cemetery this is a family and a
funeral we know nothing of but many of
us will likely experience what they're
going through as well and likely very
soon still Ram ji skynews bergamo italy